welcome back drive through pizza wow
what a dream right and it's now a
reality here in vegas let's welcome
carlo and sean compton from the new
family-owned drive-thru restaurant pizza
paisa
oh my gosh i've been trying to make sure
i say that right so explain what paisa
means it's a combination of pie and
pizza
it's like a pizza pie pizza pie that
makes sense okay and obviously you guys
are drive through so convenient and i
see a bunch of toppings so customizable
but let's start with customizable well
what do you guys think of your own pizza
basically
spread the cheese
you can't do pizza without cheese
absolutely so when you come in
we have a 10 inch pizza that's the do it
yourself diy um so basically we would
stretch the dough for you the sauce and
the cheese and then we pass it on a tray
to you and instead of you just telling
us what toppings you would like to put
on it you actually can take the scoops
and actually do it yourself so fun so
it's interactive after after we visit
you we're basically pizza chefs yeah
not really it's a great thing to maybe
bring your kids yeah absolutely okay i
love pepperoni yes yes yes all right
what's the what's the technique here how
do i can i just be really dramatic well
you could be
right but any way you want it if you
like to spread it and evenly or you
could probably okay yeah i love that you
mentioned the kids would love this so
this is like a family trip enough
number one topping them in america love
that you guys are family owned so what
separates your pizza and your
ingredients from the rest of the pizza
here in vegas it's a family tradition
and a family
style recipes
that's been around for a long long long
time right so this isn't your average
just you know
quick pizza drive-through you're you're
driving through and getting like gourmet
sit down at a really nice restaurant
pizza but we're trying to make it to
where it can be a little more fast
casual absolutely so where where was the
drive-through pizza concept inspired by
well basically the pandemic right
that makes sense
just like hamburgers uh
mcdonald's
we came up with the idea of having the
pizza
drive right by and pick up a pot that's
great that's great and that's something
we need to feel safe while we eat our
delicious food so what are the other
options that you guys have you know
dietary restrictions and things of that
nature i know one of our co-hosts is
gluten free right we have the gluten
free but it's a keto cauliflower base i
love cauliflower pizza oh my gosh you're
telling me i can drive through and get
cauliflower pizza
right it won't take about heartfelt
yes please
oh artichokes
i am not a chef clearly we've also had
fresh mozzarella if you like that okay
and also i i know that you guys have
some future plans obviously you just you
just opened but you're going to be 24
hours eventually
we love here in vegas yes
within the first couple of like months
we have a staggered ad like we're going
to add breakfast from 7 to 11 breakfast
pizzas
pizza what's on a breakfast pizza
besides eggs
we have a few different ones one of them
is more like a take on lox and bagel so
it's got like cream cheese smoked salmon
capers fresh dill things like that okay
we have 10 seconds left so tell
everybody how they can come visit you
where you guys located
1595 blue diamond road and four numbers
four seven or two
four zero five eight two four eight
there we go thank you so much i wish i
could go ahead and bake this really
quick and show you guys but it's
beautiful thank you it's beautiful thank
you so much all right you guys make sure
you visit them more las vegas now come